[Music]
[Applause]
carlos bustamante here
last year godzilla went up against his
biggest opponent yet
the global pandemic and though he got
knocked back a few times he's finally
ready to roar once again
in godzilla versus kong the trailer is
out now it's already got giant monster
movie fans speculating
as to what's going down mostly because
the big g looks like the bad guy this
time around
these are dangerous times godzilla's out
there and he's hurting people and we
don't know why
now the last time we saw him it was
ripping guidora's head off
shooting atomic laser beams and becoming
king of the monsters i mean the titans
literally
bowed down before him but apparently
someone didn't get the memo because king
kong is making his grand return to the
franchise
and he is looking for a fight kong bows
to no one
the seeds of this confrontation were
planted all the way back
in kong skull island and indeed the
ending of godzilla king of the monsters
gives us tons of easter eggs to base
some
fun theories on
[Music]
now my bet is on the return of ghidorah
in some form or another maybe mecca
ghidorah
a lot of people are saying they can see
mechagodzilla in the trailer i
personally don't see it but point it out
if you do
if you know what's going on let us know
in the comments below
and maybe more importantly are you team
godzilla
or team kong let's talk about it luckily
you don't have to wait
too long for godzilla versus kong the
movie is
out this march
is it too high is that too high for
right here how about right here
how about right there not
there is this i'm imagining that there's
a box here
watch it right here i wonder what the
what the thumbnail will be